>> Tucker: PROBABLY NO SINGLE
AMERICAN IN HISTORY HAS
ACCUMULATED MORE POWER WITHOUT
BEING ELECTED THEN DR. TONY
FAUCI.
MOST PEOPLE HAD NEVER HEARD OF
HIM BEFORE FOUR MONTHS AGO.
NOW HE RUNS THE COUNTRY.
HOW DOES HE YOU’VE USE THAT
POWER?
OFTEN TO PROMOTE WILD
SPECULATION THAT IS TAKEN AS
GOSPEL BY MILLIONS OF FEARFUL
AMERICANS.
AT ONE POINT, HE TOLD US THAT
THE CORONAVIRUS WAS SO DEADLY,
WE SHOULD NEVER SHAKE HANDS
AGAIN.
THERE GOES ONE OF THE OLDEST
TERMINATIONS KNOWN TO MAN.
HE ALSO ENDORSED BREAKING
LOCKDOWNS TO HAVE SEX WITH
STRANGERS YOU MEET ONLINE.
HE WARNED THE CORONAVIRUS IS SO
DANGEROUS THAT THE ENTIRE NFL
SEASON MAY HAVE TO BE CANCELED.
DAVE PORTNOY DID NOT VOTE FOR
ANTHONY FAUCI.
HE DID, HOWEVER, FOUND BARSTOOL
SPORTS AND WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE
THEM ON TONIGHT.
DAVID, DO YOU THINK THAT OUR
UNELECTED MONARCH TONY FAUCI IS
MAKING THE RIGHT DECISION BY
DESTROYING AMERICA’S MOST
POPULAR SPORT?
>> THE GOOD NEWS IS I DON’T
THINK HE HAS ANY ACTUAL
INFLUENCE ON IT AND IN A RARE
SITUATION, THE ONLY MAN WHO
THINKS HE WAS ELECTED WITHOUT
BEING ELECTED BY THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE MORE THAN HIM, ROGER
CADDELL, HE WOULD INFECT HIS OWN
FAMILY WITH CORONA BEFORE
CANCELING THE NFL SO I DON’T --
WHY HE HAS THE RIGHT TO SAY THAT
THEY’RE NOT, YOU CAN CERTAINLY
SAY IT MAY BE DANGER ABOUT THE
WAY HE PHRASED IT IT WAS LIKE HE
WAS THE END ALL BEYOND THAT.
I WOULD ASK BE VERY CURIOUS TO S
IF HE TRIED TO ACTUALLY INSTALL
THAT REGIME VERSUS THE ROGER
GOODELL REGIME.
>> Tucker: I DIDN’T HEAR OR
THINK SINGLE THING YOU SAID
AFTER YOU COMPLEMENTED ROGER
GOODELL.
>> IT WASN’T EXACTLY A
COMPLIMENT, I DID SAY HE WOULD
IN FACT HIS OWN FAMILY WITH
CORONAVIRUS.
ROGER GOODELL DOES NOT CARE
ABOUT SAFETY OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT, THIS COULD BE THE GREATEST
PANDEMIC OF ALL TIME, HE’S
PLAYING.
WHY DR. FAUCI THOUGHT HE HAD THE
RIGHT TO ACT LIKE HE WAS A
DECISION-MAKER, I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> Tucker: WHAT IT IS GOING TO
DO TO ATTENDANCE AT THE GAMES?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK WE’RE
SEEING RIGHT NOW, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CLEARLY HAVE COVID
FATIGUE.
WHETHER THAT’S RIGHT OR WRONG,
PEOPLE ARE SHOWING UP IN DROVES
TO CASINOS, TO BARS.
IF YOU LET PEOPLE GO TO THE
GAMES, THEY’RE GOING TO GO.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, HUMANS IN
GENERAL ARE SOCIAL CREATURES SO
THEY’LL SHOW UP.
THE ONLY WAY THEY WANT IS IF WE
PHYSICALLY ARE TOLD WE CAN’T GO,
NOT ALLOWED IN BUT IF YOU LET
PEOPLE GO, THEY ARE WILLING TO
RISK IT AND BY THE WAY I THINK
THAT SHOULD BE EACH INDIVIDUAL’S
CHOICE.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE.
WE ARE HEARING YESTERDAY THAT
IT’S POSSIBLE STADIUMS WILL TAKE
THE TEMPERATURE OR SOMEHOW TEST
EVERY PERSON WITH A TICKET
TRYING TO GET IN, WHAT WOULD
THAT LOOK LIKE, DO YOU THINK?
>> THOSE ARE PROBABLY THE
LONGEST LINES IN THE HISTORY OF
LINES.
THAT’S -- IMAGINE GETTING IN A
BAR WHEN YOU HAVE A SLOW BOUNCER
WITH YOUR I.D., IMAGINE THEM
ACTUALLY TAKING EVERYONE HE MET
A PERSON’S TEMPERATURE.
I WENT TO MICHIGAN, IT TAKES AN
HOUR AND A HALF TO GET TO THAT
STADIUM ANYWAYS.
IMPRACTICALITY IT SOUNDS
ALL RIGHT, IF YOU CAN DO IT.
HOW THEY’RE ACTUALLY GOING TO
MAKE THIS WORK -- I MEAN, YOU’RE
GOING TO HAVE TO GET TO THE GAME
NINE HOURS EARLY, YOU’RE GOING
TO HAVE MORE PROBLEMS WITH
PEOPLE CONGREGATING WAITING TO
GET IN THAT ACTUALLY GETTING IN.
>> Tucker: ONE OF THE EFFECTS
OF THE COVID-19 LOCKED DOWN, THE
QUARANTINES IS THAT PEOPLE LIVE
VERY DIFFERENT THAN THE WAY THEY
DID FOUR MONTHS AGO, A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE GAINED WEIGHT.
YOU HAVEN’T, OBVIOUSLY, BUT YOU
HAVE GROWN A VERY, VERY BUSHY
BEARD, ARE YOU GOING TO KEEP IT?
>> TUCKER, I HAVEN’T HAD A
HAIRCUT IN THREE AND A HALF
MONTHS, THE RESULTS ARE VERY
MIXED.
I’M HAVING SOME OF THE GENTLE
NATURES, THE FEMALES, SOME SAY
THEY LIKE THE GIRLS, SOME DON’T,
MY BARBER SHOP NOT OPEN YET SO
I’M VERY IN BETWEEN, I MAY LET
THE PUBLIC DECIDE AND WHEN I SAY
PUBLIC I ONLY CARE ABOUT THE
FEMALE GENDER AND LET THEM TELL
ME WHAT THEY THINK ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: DO YOU HAVE ANY
SENSE FROM YOUR INFORMAL POLLING
ON THE QUESTION WHAT THE
REACTION IS?
>> I THINK IT’S ABOUT 60/40.
TOM HANKS STYLE FROM CASTAWAY.
IT’S A TOUGH VOTE RIGHT NOW, I’M
NOT GOING TO LIE, HE CAN GO